شهدت العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم فصفا جويا
للجيش السوداني على مواقع لقوات الدعم
السريع التي ردت بمضادات الطائرات كان ذاك
خبر حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات
كيف يبدو المشهد الميداني في السودان مع
تواصل المواجهات بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع وما هي الاستراتيجيه التي يتبناها
طرفها القتال في العمليات التي يقومان بها
ضد بعضهم البعض وعلى اي نحو يمكن ان نفهم
الاهداف الاستراتيجيه التي يسعى كل طرف
لتحقيقها عبر مواصله القتال
في اليوم الاول والثاني بعد اندلاع القتال
كان الحديث من جانب قوات الرد السريع حديث
المنتصر وبان الامور في طريقها للحسم
السريع لماذا استنادا الى تصور معين ان
قوات الرد السريع وهذه قراءتي كانت مستعده
للحدث وهي التي بادرت بالحدث استنادا الى
حجم القوه وطريقه انتشار هذه القوه ويبدو
ان تقييمها لرد فعل الجيش السوداني لم يكن
دقيقا لكن ما ان انتهت اول 48 ساعه قام
الجيش السوداني بامتصاص الصدمه انجاز
التعبير وبدا في التعامل مع الاحداث بدا
باستخدام اوراق القوه الرئيسيه لديه واهم
هذه الاوراق هي سلاح الجو وبالتالي بدا
يهاجم المعسكرات بدا يهاجم التجويد بدا
يهاجم المعاقل الرئيسيه يهاجم التعزيزات
فبدات الامور تتجه باتجاه مصلحه القوات
المسلحه السودانيه وبالتالي بدانا نشاهد
ان المعارك بصوره عامه هي اقرب الى
اشتباكات بعيده واستخدام القصف الناري
اكثر من الدخول بمعارك
صداميه او معارك مباشره بان الطرفين لا
يحترمونها تله التي تم اطلاقها لماذا لان
كل طرف يدعم من خلال هذه الهدنه
بعوامل او الاشياء مهمه جدا منها عمليه
الحجز والتحشيش باعتبارها الدعم السريع
اعتمد في هذه الهدى لانه يستطيع اعراضه
الموجوده في دارفور في كردفان بعض المناطق
القوات المسلحه ايضا استطاعه تستخدم عناصر
قادمه من نهر النيل وكذلك من اشرق السودان
فبالتالي كله فرج يدعى الى تعزيز مكان
القوى اثناء هذه الهدن باي حال من الاحوال
الجديه الاخرى المهمه ايضا كل طرف يدعى
حتى لا يتم تصنيفه بانه لا رافض في
الاستمرار في قضايا الهدنه حتى يتسنى
للاجانب كذلك الخروج من السودان والجساد
الدبلوماسي
فضلا عن ذلك رغبته بوصل الى تفاهمات او
تسويه الصراع هذا في الميا وبالتالي اذا
رفض هذه الهدى سيصبح اكثر عده
بحاجه الى قوه مشتركه
مختلطه من الجيش والمدفعيه والقوات الخاصه
وقوات المشاه وتاتي خلفها قوات الشرطه
لفرض الامن بعد الاستعاده من الصعب جدا
ضمن بالرؤيه الحاليه ان يتم استعاده
السيطره الكامله على السودان مدينه
الخرطوم باركان اثلاث ضمن المدى القصير
القادم المعادله المرتبط بقياده الدعم
قياده الدعم السريع قادر انها تخرج الان
من الخرطوم وان تلتف وتذهب الى دارفور او
كردفان من بعد سقوط كفاح مسلح او تعلن
نفتح حركه مناعه على النظام وابلغ فانا في
تقدير اذا استطعت هذه القيادات الخروج من
الخرطوم يمكن ان يحدث تاثير كبير وبعض عن
النتيجه الاجتماعي في دارفور لكن اذا تم
الغاء القبض عليها او سقطت اثناء هذه
المعارك ربما المعادله تكون اقل كلفه بحيث
انه الان لاحظنا العديد من المكونات
الاجتماعيه التي تنفرض في الدعم السريع
بدات تنسحب واعاده حساباتها الا المجموعات
التي لديها مصالح وتربطها بعض خواطر
والخراب والنفق مع قياده الدعم السريع
وبالاخص محمد حمدان
[موسيقى]
دعنا ننظر الى المواقف السياسيه للطرفين
الفريق البرهاني يتحدث عن خروج قوات الدعم
السريع من الخرطوم
فيما بالمقابل الجانب الاخر يتحدث عن
القاء القبض على البرهان ومحاكمه ومجرم
حرب لاحظ الفجوه كبيره جدا اذا استمرار
القتال سيبقى قائما
لا يعلم الحرب الحرب في كل سنوات الماضي
السودان بها الا ابناء دارفور وكذلك النيل
الازرق والجنوب كردفان مجتمع الخرطوم
ومستويات بوسط السودان لم تتاثر بالحرب
كثيرا لكن في غضون الاسبوعين التي مضت انا
في تقديري كثير من المعطيات وكثير من
النظره الى ان حرب ستحل الازمه السودانيه
تتغير في مقبل الايام
[موسيقى]